hola bienvenidos a esta especial la
serie en france24 enfocado en los retos
que enfrentará el presidente entrante de
eeuu joe biden en mi nombre es andrés
meza muñoz la guerra contra las drogas
en eeuu cumple 50 años desde que el
presidente richard nixon la lanzó en
1971 según el gobierno en 2018 más de 67
mil personas murieron por sobredosis
combatir este problema será uno de los
desafíos del gobierno entrante un billón
de dólares se han gastado en eeuu y
mucho de ese dinero se ha destinado para
frenar la producción afuera de las
fronteras estadounidenses sin embargo el
consumo y la demanda en eeuu sigue en
aumento tanto que donald trump declaró
el problema de drogadicción como una
emergencia de salud pública nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez habló con jose ramirez un
drogadicto a la metanfetamina de cristal
que quiso compartir su historia con
france24
a gente que viene o venimos aquí a fumar
y a buscar sexo y la razón es porque
como ven acá hay lubricante allí hay
cuando les usado acá este
la bolsa que usualmente uno tiene se
droga puede ser que está al crack moda
lo que sea según el departamento de
salud de eeuu 57 2 millones de personas
usaron drogas ilícitas en el 2019 un
aumento de cerca de 10 millones en
comparación con el 2015 además según el
cdc más de 184 personas mueren al día
por sobredosis una emergencia de salud
pública decretada por champ que según
josé se ha empeorado con el coche y no
tenemos dónde ir o donde no tenemos
apoyo porque todo está cerrado y hoy uno
sufriendo de ansiedad es depresión de
bipolar
y de tener adicciones a la droga o de
que uno va a usar más en este tiempo
porque no sabe como la ideal no tenemos
el apoyo que necesitamos
jose encontró apoyo y trabajo en casa
rubio una organización que brinda
servicios de salud refugio y
alimentación a drogadictos ya la
comunidad lgtb y su directora rubí
corado ha acogido a más de 60.000
personas indigentes en los últimos cinco
años espero que exista un cambio pero es
difícil es difícil porque hasta el día
de hoy
han habido diferentes gobiernos locales
y federales que realmente nunca se
acercaron a preguntarle a la comunidad a
las personas que estamos en el frente de
estas batallas a preguntarnos que
necesitábamos la guerra contra las
drogas ha hecho que un quinto de la
población encarcelada en eeuu está en
prisión por crímenes relacionados con
esta casi el 80% de la población en las
cárceles son afroamericanos y latino
para hacer frente a esta emergencia la
administración bailén tiene una serie de
propuestas como invertir 125 mil
millones de dólares en servicios
eficaces de prevención tratamiento y
recuperación reformar el sistema
penitenciario para que nadie sea
encarcelado sólo por usar drogas detener
el flujo de drogas ilícitas como el
fentanilo y la heroína desde china y
méxico y responsabilizar a las grandes
empresas farmacéuticas por su papel en
la crisis de los opioides un problema
que según expertos inició con
medicamentos prescritos que cuando le
fueron suspendidos a los pacientes éstos
recurrieron al mercado ilegal
maria mcfarland sánchez moreno fue
directora de la alianza para la política
de drogas en eeuu y hoy es analista
legal senior de human rights watch
experta en temas de política global de
drogas justicia criminal y seguridad
mcfarland nos contó cuál es el reto más
grande que tiene joe biden para
enfrentar la epidemia de drogadicción en
eeuu y que debería hacer su
administración frente a esta emergencia
de salud pública
volandri
y la guerra contra las drogas ha
afectados proporcionalmente a la gente
negra y morena en eeuu los que son
arrestados y encarcelados por abuso de
drogas son desproporcionalmente negros y
morenos
y ha servido como excusa para
incrementar la fuerza policial en
comunidades de colores
algo que puede generar más interacciones
negativas entre la policía y las
personas de estas comunidades que
después contribuyen a los asesinatos de
gente negra que hemos visto y que han
generado olas de protestas partido de a
pie sin el de efectivo gabi al cast
viendo a todos estos problemas están
conectados alejarse de la guerra contra
las drogas y acercarse más a un enfoque
de apoyo que invierta más en la salud de
estas personas y en las comunidades y
que trata de resolver los problemas
sociales que pueden estar creando el
problema del uso de las drogas generis
es un camino positivo hacia el futuro
que muy probablemente además es
hasta aquí la serie de frases 24 ésta y
otras ediciones sobre los retos de joe
biden como la migración y el kobe 19 las
puede encontrar en nuestra página web
www puntos francia 24 punto com
[Música]